please begin thank you okay uh thank you
corey
okay uh first uh good afternoon to
everyone
and we will try to give you an update of
where we are with the vaccination
campaign
and uh and we will also uh
address your questions at the end of
this presentation
so first i
i want to share with you that until
until early this morning the the total
number of
vaccination doses
a minute here in clark county uh was
107 000. those
those fascinations have been ammunition
by the the healthy street
staff and our partners
across the county the the different
cities
in las vegas henderson
nor las vegas also our partners at the
universities unfree grossman toro
as well as all the hospitals in the area
and and all they provided it has been
a common effort across the the county to
be able to deliver those shots
we as so much you might know
we are struggling with the number of
vaccines that we are receiving
in weekly basis and and this is so this
is
also something that is limited
limiting our ability to offer more
vaccinations to our community
and and we have been chaired before
by chief steinberg and many of our
partners and
we just want to emphasize that we have
enough capacity here to administer a
more vaccine that we're doing right now
we we
we estimate that we have between 95 and
12
and 5 000 vaccines
doses that we could laminate through our
size here in the county
but right now our allocations are very
limited we are receiving
about 22 23 000 doses of vaccine
a week so it's important it's important
to share that with you
because i know we know that there are
many questions about
when will i be vaccinated you know
most of our
residents are asking that question
i i also want to mention that they held
the street
in in partnership with the las vegas
convention center
will start offering the the second dose
of vaccine
to all those who receive the first dose
at healthy street locations and
also the cosmos center so
basically it refers to three locations
a casman the main
the main facility of the health the
street at
and western high school uh
everybody else who received the first
dose
at any of our partners they
they are scheduled or will be a schedule
to receive the second dose at the
at those locations so it's important to
clarify that
and also we will be offering
the second dose of vaccine at the
convention center for
for the next a few weeks and
once we receive a large
large achievements of vaccine then a
second dose of the vaccine
will be offered a multiple sites beyond
the convention center and the initial
places where people might have received
the vaccine
i i also wanted to briefly touch
the the issue of the the the new variant
that was identified here in in grant
county
it was reported by the state uh public
health lab
this week that there was a patient a
female
in her studies that was diagnosed with
with
with kobe uh but when our lab period
in southern nevada started looking at
the specimen from this patient
they they noticed that there were
certain elements in the structure of the
virus that
that were inconsistent with say what we
have
usually seen and because of that
this specimen was was a
a transfer to to the lab
in reno because they have the capability
to do
more advanced studies and that's how
this strain was identified this is the
strain
that is currently circulating in the uk
is called the b
seven strain which is considered
to be a more more aggressive
in terms of ability to disseminate
um and spread their disease among people
but is not considered to be a
more a little of
of generating more complications when
compared to
to the the usual variants that we have
here
in in southern nevada the the preventive
measures
for this new strain remain the same that
we
recommend for uh for this disease from
the beginning of the pandemic
again uh you know keeping social
distances at least six feet distance
when we are in public places also
the use of faster covering of mass
and hang watching as well as other
mitigation measures that we have been
advocating through this year okay
having said this i will stop here and
i will ask a consumer man
scott black who is the chairman of our
board of health
to participate in this thank you
thank you so much dr lagann the southern
nevada health district
has all along and continues continues to
work closely with our
jurisdictional partners as we work
through this vaccine
rollout process and um are really our
goal is to make sure that everyone who
desires a vaccine
that is currently eligible to receive it
through the
the lane program that we have that will
they will receive it that's our absolute
goal dr lagun mentioned that throughout
our community we have
developed a capacity to administer
much higher amount of doses to our
community then we have the supply to
support that
and the good news is as the surprise
we are certainly able to scale up for
our community
and really fulfill the needs and
maximize the distribution to our
community
we're working closely with the state who
is working closely with the cdc and fema
and our federal delegation
to increase the doses available for
southern nevada and as those
dosage amounts increase we're certainly
ready to take those doses
they won't sit they'll be put out into
the community and into the arms of those
individuals
that desire and are eligible for the
vaccine i think it's important to
to note that this is of course an
unprecedented set of circumstances that
we're facing
it's a community-wide undertaking and
our efforts
as a health district along with all of
our partners both public and private are
really
making it possible to do what we're
doing uh you may ask yourself
dr lagann he's the doctor here and he
mentioned a moment ago
what can we do as individuals clearly
all along
we've been asked to wear a mask in
public to wash our hands
thoroughly and frequently to socially
distance when in public
he mentioned those things those things
are so critical to maintain and continue
and one more thing that you can do as a
community member as as your eligibility
comes up
to please take the opportunity to sign
up and and register for an appointment
to receive the vaccine if we all
continue to do these things
together we'll be able to collectively
stop the pandemic here in southern
nevada and
open up for business and and get back to
normal so thank you so much dr lagann
and your team for your excellent work
and for all of our community partners
for their leadership
and health
start till again you're muted
sorry thank you okay thank you
consignment black
i will have a chief steinbeck
to proceed
tackle again i don't have any comments
i'm just here to
answer any questions that might come up
thank you okay thank you
okay then we go we go to a joanna
piper she's our chief amazing nurse and
she has been leading
the vaccination campaign for the health
district yuan please
well good afternoon everyone and uh
thank you for attending
our media events so that we can get the
information out
um every things seem to be improving
every week
and our capacity is really
coming along very well we just need
vaccine
and we will be able to vaccinate this
community and get
get everyone back to work
okay thank you uh
corey will you please open for questions
yes sir our first question today comes
from ms jacqueline schultz
please go ahead
jacqueline are you there
okay we'll try jacqueline again in just
one second let's go to lauren from
lauren clark from channel 3 i'm muting
you now
lauren are you there
all right we may be experiencing some
technical difficulties let's keep going
down the list until
we hear somebody okay joe you're up next
all right can you hear me everybody yes
sir all right there we go
um today i noticed that walgreens is
actually on the appointments
for the vaccine are you able to talk
about uh
more locations such as pharmacies
opening up this week
um when it comes to getting the vaccine
option now because smith's is on there
and so is walgreens but we haven't
really seen
much or heard much about them okay thank
you you and you want to take that sure
so uh some of the uh pharmacies are
receiving vaccine and their target
population is 70 and up
and uh walgreens and cvs have started uh
appointments
and more are to come uh savon is
is coming on smith's is also an option
and you can reach those appointments at
nevadakovidfighter.org
let's try jacqueline again see if if
we can hear her this time are you there
jacqueline
okay still having trouble let's try
lauren again
lauren can um is it working
okay i'll try you again jacqueline typed
her question to the chat box what's the
prospect and timeline for getting
through the next tiers
are we going to focus on the current
groups
okay um i will start and join you
a lot after that well right now
we are working through
70 years old and over uh and just to
give you a perspective
the total number of seniors that we have
in that group in clark county
is over 200 000 people
so it's important to keep that
perspective uh
at the same time we we are working with
a
with a second lane which is the the
workforce
um we are vaccinating
healthcare providers still we're
vaccinating healthcare providers
we are also vaccinating
responders with you know within the
safety
group and and also we are
a vaccinating
members of the of the frontline
workforce such as educators
also members of
of another priority group that they
are working closely with people
with special needs and
and then uh what is the other group that
we have joanne
because we we stopped at the at the
governors which is the
right yeah yeah between
governance and and transportation that's
where the cutoff is for the essential
worker on the other side is 70 and up
on the age side so those are the groups
that we're
vaccinating right now i would expect
since it is a large group
clark county school district itself is
like 40 to 50 000 people
so i would expect that we would be
staying there for at least a couple
weeks
next up today is mary hines
can you hear me okay great
um i'm wondering um in terms of
who is eligible right now if anyone who
works in a healthcare office
in any capacity can be vaccinated right
now
and can anyone who works in a school in
any capacity
be vaccinated right now well as far
as far as medical yes um they can
uh be vaccinated for school i i
it depends because that's a newer group
and so um some of i i think there
there is a plan for ccsd working with
unlv to get a plan
there may be some limitations there i i
think uh
i can't say for clark county school
district but my understanding there is a
vaccination plan and they are um
uh they do have uh a groups that they
are
prioritizing right uh you and let me add
into that
uh regarding the school system they
that your answer is everybody who's
working at this
at the school system whether it is a
private schools or county school
district
they are eligible to be vaccinated at
this
at this phase uh specifically for cloud
country school district
they they created their their own
prior priority groups if you wish
and and based on that priority groups
they are being vaccinated
today thank you
uh lauren from channel 3 has asked for a
question in the chat box when can
residents expect to move to the next
lanes so like the 65 and older
65 to 69 group when will they expect to
be eligible
okay we as i mentioned before
we have over 200 people in grant county
who are 70 years old and over
and we are receiving about
22 000 doses of vaccine
a week so unless the allocation of
vaccine
change and we don't do not have control
with that
we are several weeks i would say before
we can actually move into
into the next group and it's not because
we don't want to it just because
there is no vaccine
thank you okay our next voice question
comes from alexander zapata
i'm muting you now
dr legend see my question is going to be
in spanish sorry
dr legend hold on hold on
okay corey
corey said that spanish will be at the
end i don't want to violate what he
already
said and so that's great i can't wait
don't worry
yeah thank you we'll definitely we'll
definitely come back to you
um i promise okay let's go on to
astrid mendes muting you now there you
go
hello everyone um since you were talking
about the teacher's uh vaccination
um actually ccsc released well basically
a memo to their employees saying that
now
they can register to get access to the
vaccine
i was wondering uh what is the
relationship that you're having with
them about it
if there's already like an established
number of vaccines that
have been already allocated to them
obviously they need to prove that their
employees with ccsd
but of course there's still a lot of
questions about you know
how many uh can they do this they have
this
sure i mean keep in mind we're getting
like dr lagann said we're getting
anywhere from 22 to 25 000 per week
so you unlv is actually managing ccsd
so that email i think was um
a couple of weeks ago so i think there's
a newer plan
and i think they are prioritizing their
list just like we did with the hospitals
where we prioritize those who would be
you know
on the front lines that's what i
understand ccsd is doing
so employees really should wait from
guidance
if they work for a large organization
they should look
they should go to their employer and say
is there a vaccination plan
and uh that that is the best approach at
this point
uh jeff gillam you're gillan you're up
next
up good afternoon everybody uh this is
for anyone
at the health district perhaps joanne
you could wean on this or scott black
but uh
if you could you walk me through if and
when you get
more vaccine just exactly how you would
be able
to scale up and and what the plans would
be what that would mean what
would that be 24-hour sites would that
be
drive-through sites just exactly what
would you do with more vaccine sure
um i'm actually looking at my
spreadsheet right now
on this issue so with um
with the capacity we have right now we
could probably do
um about 80 000
per week our goal is around a hundred
thousand per week
now we have to consider the second dose
in there
but i'm pretty confident we can
certainly do 50 000 per week
with with our current capacity as we
build our capacity
uh we're looking at a hundred thousand
per week in
uh march
and joanne what what jeff alluded to
also are
also potential scenarios for us such as
24-hour sites driving
all those things that he mentioned yeah
are all uh perspective aspects to our
plan as we scale up
but the existing capacity that we have
is
is what joanne indicated you know well
into the the tens of thousands upwards
of 80 000
we're just working closely with the
state with the federal government to
up our allocation and once we do that
we'll be able to incorporate more
large-scale pods megapods if you will
more strike team aspects to areas of the
community that have
mobility issues potentially 24-hour
sites all those things that you
mentioned will be
part of our uh our multi-pronged
approach to reach everybody as quickly
as possible
we have two large pods right now
uh one's doing first dose one's doing
second dose
at las vegas convention center second
dose cachement is first dose
and then uh we have the capacity here
the health district and all of our
partners
with just that capacity it's around
forty fifty thousand
so we that's just operating five days a
week
eight eight hours a day that's not even
due in 24 hours so
um with uh another
two large pods to do the second doses we
we would uh easily be able to do that
capacity
and without even having to do the
24-hour thing
so uh we have a lot of vaccinators here
we're getting uh
some help from fema national guard
uh the fire department's been awesome uh
helping us out with this
and uh and so when we're ready to really
open up
for the public uh we'll be ready around
march april for that
yeah thank you maybe would you
would you like to add to that from your
perspective
i'm sorry dr legan was that for me yeah
i was asking
if you would you like to add to that
yeah
yeah sure absolutely so i agree with
joanne i think that
in fact i'm even more optimistic on on
the numbers there a little bit as
as we take a look at the at the
spreadsheets there
um rsnhd uh so just the sites that snhd
is
is supporting uh shows 94 370 today
those numbers continue to be adjusted so
we really think we could put that
together and
and and be pushing that out
um each week uh starting today if we had
uh
had the additional uh uh vaccines
um certainly as well uh you know to the
more general question how would
for instance cashman's site um it's
running just over a thousand now
it's only because of vaccine limitations
and that would instantly be up to
over 3000 a day you look at that scale
all the way across
at the different sites everybody can do
more and that is just like joanne said
without expanding hours
and without expanding additional sites
and
certainly the the model that's at
cashman at canyon springs
and that even some of the smaller pods
can be replicated now
so it's a resource request we add
additional personnel there
and we can have multiple sites like that
so the question that
have we considered drive-thru sites yes
absolutely we have
plans in place to to do drive-through
sites if that's uh
going to be the the best operation for
us
but there just hasn't been the vaccine
to to enact those
um and we've had a tremendous response
from the community of offering sites so
everything from public to private
locations uh this is what people want
right now
the community wants to provide this so
we get calls all the time of hey
how about this site how about that site
we'll do whatever we can for you
and we'd love to take advantage of that
but
none of it matters without uh additional
vaccine quantities
right thank you chief i i would also
like to add to
to you and and and chief comments that
uh
a another opportunity that we have here
is our partnership with the private
industry that we
haven't uh incorporate into our response
but
uh is there is a willingness to
participate on this and we certainly
will reach out to them
when we are in in a position to
to administer more vaccines thank you
in the chat box specifically for joanne
um people wanted to clarify something
that was said earlier
um rhonda press just wants to clarify
that the following folks in the
frontline community support lane are
still not eligible
essential public transportation mortuary
services and remaining essential public
health workforce
she says rideshare drivers have been
turned away they've heard
that's correct yes there was some
confusion about
the transportation what exactly that
meant
for essential uh public transfer
transportation it meant ground
transportation when you look at the
definitions
and if you go to our website and click
on that um
on that section it'll give the
definition but
um essential transportation means
like bus drivers that type of thing and
ride share and we're cutting it off
right there we have to
we have to cut it off somewhere so that
we can concentrate on the other priority
groups
up ahead
we've also had a couple of questions in
the chat asking about
when people are going to be getting
their emails about the second doses and
and so forth and uh our
communications manager has been
responding to those so i just want to
recap for anyone who's not seeing the
chat
um she was saying that the emails have
already been distributed and people did
receive a link to schedule an
appointment
um there was another question about our
changing our appointment system and why
we did that
and um we said the new system
will integrate both the appointment and
the registration process so people don't
complete
have to complete the registration
paperwork on site and it'll speed up the
process and cut down on data entry
did anybody want to expand upon any of
that
right our our system basically we went
to an electronic system
on site at the clinics so the
appointment
was part was the initiation to that
system
so that information in electronically
and we can get it also up to nevada webi
z quicker so we can get our data entry
completed on-site
lauren clark is also asking aside from
neighbors reaching out to eligible
non-long-term living care
seniors are there any strike teams
additional resources
helping them make an appointment many
have expressed lack of internet or
computing
i lost corey did you hear me did you
hear any of them no we lost
a bit of it talking about long-term care
and and reaching out
yeah so there were any strike teams or
resources because i guess
some have expressed lack of internet or
computer access right
so um the long-term care like for
example like nursing homes
assisted living those were taken care of
by the pharmacy
pharmacies and um cvs and walgreens
now there were some of those places that
didn't qualify
with that federal program but now the
state is
uh is setting up those pharmacies to go
to
uh those others that did not qualify so
that's another group that will
be taken care of and we are asking
neighbors and family members to help
their
loved ones over 70 get appointments
we are we are we do have a phone number
um four appointments at this time
for those second doses when that is
when we get that center up uh
up their capacity and also we're working
with the state on their phone number
to assist uh uh over 70
then we'll let the media know and and
let our
folks know a lot of the over 70 groups
through the senior centers
are getting direct access through
through like um
through the senior centers they have
lists of people and they
people and help them but we do need to
do some work on this to get
more outreach jeff gillen's following up
with the question the capacity that we
currently have the 40 to 50 000
is that per week are we administering
all of it and with more could you take
that up to a hundred thousand doses per
week
so right now we have a capacity of the
whole of southern nevada
of around 22 25 000 somewhere in there
that's what we're allotted
allocated our capacity is much higher
it's twice that
so it's not that is not the issue it's
getting the
vaccine from the federal government so
um our capacity probably is more i'm
looking here
uh probably a 60 000 and uh with
us with a few more pods we could easily
i think get it up to a hundred thousand
i think
chief steinbeck would say yes and
uh that's where we are we have to
consider how we're gonna do second dose
so we would actually need a capacity of
200 000 per week if we wanted to do that
and ask true mendez has follow-up
questions how many vaccines are
allocated to
ccsd that wasn't the right
answer yeah i i am not sure how much a
unlv
is getting but as a as all of southern
nevada we're
we're getting 12 25 000.
so there's not a specific allocation for
ccsd
uh but unlv it really is based on their
capacity and how much they order
okay right now we don't have any more
raised hands or questions to the chat
box so
in a moment we will move on to the
spanish language questions but first
does anybody have any
wrap up comments before we move on
hey just on behalf of committee she was
unable to unmute
and to join this today so she just
wanted to give her support to all of the
community partners
that are assisting with this effort and
let everybody know that she is she is
pushing as hard as possible and working
as hard as possible
on behalf of our community to get more
vaccines to our community
that we can push out in mass thank you